il va avoir un nouveau visage en 2026 le
quartier de l'hôpital va devenir un éco
quartier à saint germain en laye 5000 m²
de commerces 450 logements une crèche
une résidence seniors ou encore une
maison médicale un projet de
réaménagement qui prévoit quelques
destructions
ce n'est pas une opération de
construction c'est plutôt un projet
autour du bien-être du cadre de vie des
habitants de saint germain et puis c'est
aussi conserver le patrimoine
hospitalier du 19e le rénover ça a été
vraiment pensé comme un nouveau quartier
mais ouvert sur le reste du centre
ancien le lien social sera privilégiée
avec un espace de rencontres entre
habitants avec la conciergerie autres
secteurs privilégiés le loisir avec un
cinéma ugc un hôtel de 80 chambres et un
restaurant panoramique installé en haut
d'un des deux châteaux d'eau c'est tout
à fait exceptionnel et je pense que ça
permet aussi d'attirer pas mal de
personnes extérieures à saint germain
s'est aussi trouvé le moyen pour que un
des deux dômes des châteaux d'eau
puissent est accessible de manière
totalement gratuite au public qu'ils
puissent profiter du panorama le
patrimoine historique sera préservée
notamment avec cette église ce nouvel
écoquartier sera piéton et cyclable
aujourd'hui le projet rentre dans une
nouvelle phase dans quelques semaines le
permis d'aménager et les permis de
construire vont être instruit par la
ville
il va y avoir une maison projet qui
devrait ouvrir dans les semaines qui
viennent
en centre ville les premières
démolitions vont débuter à l'été 2000 21
l'ensemble du projet sera réalisé par
tranches jusqu'en 2026 date prévue pour
la livraison